en effet il ya un paradoxe de voir trump
et essayer justement d'interdire une
application où il ya de la il y a de la
liberté d'expression qui est qui était
mise en faveur notamment d'une amérique
qui serait justement débarrasser de ce
récit sme systémique en faveur de
féministes qui serait qu'ils seraient
respectés
donc c'est intéressant de voir puisque
cette interdiction que trump veut le
faire peser sur ce type top parce que
justement notamment quand on observe
facebook ou même twitter vous avez une
conception de la liberté d'expression
qui est implémenté qui est très
étasunienne qui reprend exactement le
titre de votre émission c'est à dire ce
qu'on appelle la liberté négative il est
interdit d'interdire
et donc c'est cette idée que on va
proposer des plates formes d'expression
qui permettent un libre commerce des
idées et a même un concurrence des idées
et dans laquelle justement la vérité va
être fixée dans des transactions qui
sont justement de plus en plus
aujourd'hui compétitive concurrentiel
antagonistes et voilà donc ça c'est
c'est un peu paradoxal en effet de voir
trump qui finalement au nom cette
liberté d'expression très particulière
qui de cette caractérisation très
particulière la liberté d'expression et
aux etats-unis bien voudrait interdire
en effet ce qui est une plate forme dans
laquelle ou une application dans
laquelle est bien il ya eu justement des
opinions contre trump qui on est et qui
ont été émises
[Musique]